so to set the initial linear velocity we
simply pass it a vector to object now
for our simple projectile we have a
little bit of a nuance here because what
happens is once the projectile is
created we pass it in a directional X&Y
representing the vector of travel for
this projectile alongside its speed
object so this basically says move this
direction this much per frame now again
we've set this as the initial linear
velocity on the physics body and of
course once the first update the loop
happens we'll actually remove the
velocity from the object and we need to
set it again inside of the update
function we set it to the same value the
same speed